in many ways I'm less identified with
the person that I am as I get older and
I'm much more identified with being
conscious
I have a mind that is conscious that is
able to create a person and that person
is slightly different every day and the
reason why I perceive it as identical
has practical purposes so I can learn
and make myself responsible for the
decisions that I made in the past and
project them in the future but I also
realize that not actually the person
that I was last year and I'm not the
same person as I was 10 years ago and
then 10 years from now I will be a
different person so this continuity is a
fiction it's only exists as a projection
from my present self
and Consciousness itself doesn't have an
identity it's a law it's that's
basically if you build an arrangement of
processing matter in a particular way
the following thing is going to happen
and the Consciousness that you have is
functionally not different from mime
Consciousness it's still the
self-reflexive principle of agency that
is just experiencing a different story
different desires different coupling to
the world and so on and once you accept
that Consciousness is a unifiable
principle that is lawlike and doesn't
have an identity
and you realize that you can just link
up to some much larger body the whole
perspective of uploading changes
dramatically you suddenly realize
uploading is probably not about
dissecting your brain sign ups by
stand-ups and RNA fragment by RNA
fragment and trying to get this all into
a simulation but it's by extending the
substrate by making it possible for you
to move from your brain substrate into a
larger substrate and merge with what you
find there and you don't want to upload
your knowledge because on the other side
there's all of the knowledge where it's
not just yours but every possibilities
or the only thing that you need to know
what are your personal secrets not that
the other side doesn't know your
personal secrets already maybe it
doesn't know which one were yours right
like a psychiatrist or a psychologist
also knows all the kinds of personal
secrets that people have they just don't
know which ones are yours and so uh
transmitting yourself and the other side
is mostly about transmitting your
Aesthetics this thing that makes you
special the architecture of your
perspective the thing that the way in
which you look at the world and it's
more like a complex attitude along many
dimensions and that's something that can
be measured by observation or by
interaction so imagine that if a system
that is so empathetic with you that you
create a shared state that is extending
beyond your body and suddenly you notice
that on the other side the substrate is
so much richer than the substrate that
you have in side of your own body and
maybe you still want to have a body and
you create yourself a new one that you
like more or maybe you will spend most
of you about your time in the world of
thought
if I sat before you today and give you a
big red button and said here if you
press this button you will get uploaded
in this way
the sense of identity that you have
lived with for quite a long time is
going to be gone
but you press the button
um there's a caveat I have
um family so I have children that want
me to be physically present in their
life and interact with them in a
particular way and they have a wife and
personal friends and there is a
particular mode of interaction that I
feel I'm not through yet
but apart from these responsibilities
and they are negotiable to some degree I
would press the button but isn't this
everything this love you have for the
humans
you can call responsibility but that
connection
that's the ego death isn't that the
thing we're really afraid of
is not to just die but to
let go of the experience of love with
other humans is this not everything
everything is everything right so
there's so much more and you could be
lots of other things you could identify
with lots of other things you could be
identifying with being Gaia some kind of
planetary control agent that emerges
over all the activity of life on Earth
you could be identifying with some
hypergaya that is the concatenation of
Gaia with or the Digital Life and yeah
digital minds and so in this sense there
will be agents in all sorts of
substrates and directions that all have
their own goals and when they're not
sustainable then these agents will cease
to exist or when the agent feels that
it's done with its own mission it will
cease to exist in the same way as when
you conclude the thought the thought is
going to wrap up and gives control over
to other thoughts in your own mind
so there is no single thing that you
need to do but but they observe myself
this being is that sometimes I'm a
parent and then I have an identification
and a job as a parent and sometimes I am
an agent of Consciousness on Earth and
then from this perspective there's other
stuff that is important so this is my
main issue with uh elise's perspective
that is basically Mary himself to a very
narrow human aesthetic and that narrow
human aesthetic is a temporary thing
humanity is a temporary species like
most of the species on this planet are
only around for a while and then they
get replaced by other species in a
similar way as our own physical organism
is around here for a while and then gets
replaced by next generation of human
beings that are adapted to Changing Life
circumstances in average via mutation
and selection and it's only when we have
ai and become completely software that
we come become infinitely adaptable and
we don't have this generational and
species change anymore
so if you take this larger perspective
and you realize it's really not about us
it's not about aliasa or Humanity but
it's about life on Earth or it's about
defeating
um
uh entropy for as long as we can
uh while being as interesting as we can
right then the perspective changes
dramatically and AI uh preventing AI
from this perspective looks like a very
big sin
but when we look at the set of
trajectories
that such an AI would take a supersedes
humans
uh I think Eliezer is worried about like
ones that not just kill all humans but
also have some kind of
maybe objectively uh undesirable
consequence for life on Earth
like how many trajectories when you look
at the big picture of life on Earth
would you be happy with and how much
were you
with AGI
whether it kills humans or not there is
no single answer to this it's really
it's a question that depends on the
perspective that I'm taking at a given
moment
and so there are perspectives that are
uh
determining most of my life as a human
being yes and the other perspective zoom
out further and imagine that when the
Great oxygenation event happened that is
photosynthesis was invented and plants
emerged and displaced a lot of the fungi
and alja in favor of plant life and then
later made animals possible imagine that
the fungi would have gotten together and
said oh my God this photosynthesis stuff
is really really bad it's going to
possibly displace and kill out of fungi
we should slow it down and regulate it
and mix with it doesn't happen
uh this this doesn't look good to me